listen first congratulations on the
movie
uh but i am curious uh i know you love
so many different projects
if you could get the financing for
anything tomorrow
what would you make and why oh my god
what a great question
too good a question quite frankly i
probably
would make
the barca trilogy
opt for the carthaginian general and i
would
try to um
kind of create something hart mel gibson
part frank miller
and really try to
take a fresh take on on the punic wars
that's where i would put that that's
what if if i could do anything tomorrow
i would direct uh
the hannibal barker trilogy i know you
you've talked i've
talked to you a number of times and
you've always talked about this
it's clearly a real passion it is and
and as you know steve sometimes those
passion projects take quite some time to
make and
so i'm still on that road
i know you and justin have the keys to
the kingdom in terms of where
knowing where fast is going ultimately
have you and justin figured out
exactly where this whole thing is going
to end like what that final shot is
going to be
um i have
a scene that's reoccurring
um and has been quite some time for
for maybe years now of what i've
always imagined the finale of the finale
would be
um and justin and i have talked
to great lengths and we've worked
towards that so much of nine was getting
prepped and ready for
the two-part finale of the saga
so could i articulate it now
or would i articulate it out i might not
be you know able to do that but what's
what's unique about this release steve
is that
we clearly had to push a release a year
and that push we pushed into
our pre-production of this two-part
fast ten finale so i'm every day
coming to talk about fast nine going
home when working on fast 10.
i really hope this is a huge hit for you
and i can't wait to see what it's all
gonna ultimately be
thank you so much steve it's a very
exciting moment
um it's it's really bizarre talking
about the finale of something
maybe i didn't anticipate how uh
emotional people would
get um just
a few weeks ago um
i told my oldest daughter that 10 would
be the last of this
era and she started to cry i can't tell
you how bad i felt obviously
um why am i telling you that
because you care about film and you
understand that every story needs
a finale um and that's where we're going
again thank you so much um and uh have a
fantastic day
always awesome to talk with you you too
steve